let's take some questions the last time
we are taking questions in 2016 wow wow
it has been quite a year first question
today came in via voicemail 2192 david p
free personal question very interesting
one though hey David um my question was
regarding showering I was wondering if
you had a routine for drying off um I
always used to get out of the shower and
then towel off and then someone that
lived in my building in college taught
me to stay in the shower yell often
there to that way you're not dripping
onto the floor I was wondering if you
had any thoughts on that also yeah
Rachel had any thoughts well then let
but well we'll get to pat's thoughts in
a second rachel not not in today on this
question uh I do have a routine and it's
sort of twofold number one as soon as I
turn the water off I will open the door
my shower as a good or wow I will open
the door and grabbed the towel and
immediately close the door because it
gets the cold air will rush in
immediately okay so I grabbed the towel
and then I close the door there's I
would keep the towel in the in the the
shower area but it's way too small right
it would just get soaked and then I
close the door to try to keep some of
the steam in and then i do wait
something like 15 to 20 seconds to allow
gravity to do what it can and allow
water to sort of naturally flow off of
me you with me so far yes that's
fantastic okay then I take the you know
how tolls have two sides I didn't know
this until recently but the fibers uh I
don't know the column really but the
fibers on most towels are slightly
different on one side than the other and
I use the side where the fibers are
slightly longer to dry my ears and it's
very uncomfortable to me when I have
water left in my ears so I will actually
again turn my head and dry my ears with
the towel wow you ok so far have I won't
Ellingham yeah and then I will basically
dry myself with the towel from top down
right what's the point of drying your
legs before your head if you are going
to have water dripping from your head
back down to your leg so I will again
start at the top and work my way down
ending with my feet then I will step out
onto the bath mat and at that point I
will sort of do uh you know like another
once over just to make sure that I'm
properly dry and I find that that works
pretty well for me well now I know yeah
yeah I mean I don't have a routine when
it comes to this I change it up every
day you have to have some sort of
variety in your day-to-day routine
sometimes I will stay in the shower and
towel off there sometimes I'll step out
sometimes I'll start with my hair
sometimes I'll start with my legs you
gotta change it up see I truly find that
unusual only because for me the entire
process is completely um automated and
sequential I've been showering in the
exact same way basically since I started
showering when I was 27 I start I took
baths until I was 27 now I'm kidding
about that I started sharing long before
that I want to eliminate decision-making
anywhere in my day that I can uh so
doing the exact same routine every time
as part of how I do that even the length
of my showers will vary sometimes it's
two minutes sometimes it's as long as 20
I used to have this weird thing where I
would like sit down on the ledge of the
shower and I would enjoy that quite a
big deal I'm finding some of this a
little bit disturbing I'm gonna lie yeah
it's interesting uh no but my okay well
there you go my routine the same every
time Pat routine different each time uh
you live and learn you live and learn
and I think everybody can take something
from this reminds me of a of a Seinfeld
episode when Kramer showed up and was
taking notes in terms of people shower
routines to figure out what he could cut
out and what he could add and optimize
etcetera classic Seinfeld episode I know
if you've seen that one no but I hear he
got beat up from doing that as I can
understand yeah